so where we left off in the last video
we had alexander the great consolidating
his power over the macedonian empire and
in particular he
puts down a rebellion in thebes destroys
the city which makes the other
city-states of greece say hey we're not
going to mess with this person anymore
and then alexander says i am now going
to conquer asia i'm now going to conquer
the persian empire do what my father
wanted to do before he died
and so he puts one of his father's
generals now one of his generals in
charge of greece and tippeter
and tippeter declares him regent and
then leads troops off to
what many people say is have the
greatest or many historians call the
greatest adventure of all time his
attempt to conquer the persian empire
and become the king of asia so the year
is 334
bce and the first major battle that
alexander and his
army encounters is at the granicus river
here in modern day turkey
now keep in mind that alexander's force
depending on what time we're looking at
it numbers between 40 and 50 000 troops
a good number of them
infantry some cavalry
and most of the battles that we'll see
him fight especially the next two
against the persian forces he's hugely
outnumbered but at granicus he actually
has an advantage in terms of the number
of infantry he has his he's slightly
outnumbered in terms of cavalry but he's
able to defeat the persian forces now
these persian forces they are
significant they're led by the persian
satraps these are the governors of the
of the territories i guess you could say
the persian regions or provinces in this
area in asia minor and he's able to
defeat them but as important as granicus
is he still alexander still has not come
directly against darius iii darius the
third is the shansha the king of kings
the king of persia and not to confuse
darius iii with the darius who 150 years
before this attacked greece so now you
have alexander his first decisive
victory against the persians he makes
his way down the anatolian coast in his
mind liberating many of these cities
that used to be greek cities now if we
zoom in a little bit you can see the way
this map is set up
let me zoom in a little bit
where you see
these dotted lines around us around the
city this means that alexander's forces
sieged the city they surrounded it they
didn't let anything go in or out until
the city surrendered and so you see this
path of alexander and his forces we then
go into 333 bce outside of the the
forward movement of alexander and his
troops and their ability to take over
all of asia minor modern-day turkey in
only a matter of a little more than a
year what also happens in 333 bce since
some of you might have been wondering
well whatever happens to sparta phillip
of macedon never took over sparta do
they stay independent forever and the
simple answer is no in 33 33 bce
antipater defend defeats the spartans at
the battle of megalopolis and forces
them into what we now call the league of
corinth so let's keep now going back to
where alexander is so antipater clearly
was competent at maintaining power in
greece
and the next major battle that alexander
and his troops face is at isis and what
makes isis significant is that
they are hugely outnumbered historians
disagree by how much they're outnumbered
remember we said alexander's forces were
around 40 or 50 000 while the persians
at isis depending on which account you
look at were
at least 150 000 probably over a hundred
thousand more ancient accounts talk
about many hundreds of thousands or even
a million troops what also made isis
significant is this is where this is the
first time that darius iii the shan shah
the king of persia directly confronts
alexander well alexander once again is
able to or at least here is able to to
over overcome uh unlikely odds and
defeat the persian army sending darius
into retreat
and he retreats so fast he even leaves
an encampment where his mother his wife
and his two daughters are there and
alexander then takes them captive but
treats them very nicely and then
eventually marries one of the daughters
so after that defeat darius is on the
retreat and alexander or after that
defeat for davarius this victory for
alexander alexander then goes on into
the levant modern day syria and lebanon
and israel and palestine
and you can see he takes siege of the
town of the cities of tyre in gaza but
by the time he gets through that it's
now 332 and he makes his way into egypt
and he's relatively unopposed the traps
in egypt to say okay you know what we
recognize you they treat him as a
liberator and he even takes a pretty
large detour to go to the oracle for the
god amon amman and there he is
he is reassured that he is the son of
ammon and he already is told by his
mother olympia that he is the son of
zeus and so many people call alexander
or he calls himself now alexander zeus
ammon the son of zeus ammon so once
again he's trying to really make himself
or maybe he believes himself that he is
half god that he is a demigod but then
he continues on with this i guess you
could say grand adventure and i don't
want to romanticize it too much because
even though he is in some way
conquering and or unifying these large
areas
there's also a lot of
bloodshed a lot of civilians dying this
is a very ugly thing
that only looks romantic from maybe a
distance of many thousands of years but
when you think about it it would not
have been very pleasant to live to have
lived in any of these cities that
alexander and his troops are going
through
but then he leaves egypt and the whole
time after the defeat of isis darius
keeps
sending him
uh entreaties to say hey maybe we can
work this thing out maybe you can just
stop
to the west of the euphrates i'll give
you this or that but alexander keeps
saying nope not for me i want to be the
king of asia there's only one king of
asia
and so they eventually meet again at
gagamella once again a very significant
battle in
history where once again darius is there
and has a
a significant force advantage over
alexander and this time doesn't make the
mistake of meeting him in a relatively
narrow area where his force advantage
won't really be an advantage but even at
gagamella alexander is able to
decisively defeat him and darius has to
flee over the mountains to ecbat
my apologies because i know i'm probably
not pronouncing it perfectly
and alexander and his forces then go on
to capture babylon and susa and susa was
actually one of the capitals of the
achaemenid empire so this whole way
they're able to get all of this treasure
and start sending it back to greece
and then we eventually get to and by
this point having been defeated at isis
and now gagamella and being on the run
the the persian empire is you could say
it's already fallen or it's definitely
falling but it becomes really official
once we get to 3 30 bce
330 bc remember this is less than five
years since alexander started and that's
short by any time frame but they're on
foot and on horseback this is not modern
warfare where they have
tanks and trucks and planes and the fact
that conquer so much territory and
empires over 200 years old in this short
amount of time of frame is is kind of
breathtaking but it's in 3 30 where the
forces go to
the achaemenid capital of persepolis the
capital for over 200 years and they sack
that town and not only do they sack that
town they destroy the town and i'll
repeat it again alexander the great he's
romanticized a lot he's called the great
but they destroy that town in a way that
uh you you would not make your parents
proud let's just put it that way but at
that point he is now king of the persian
empire darius is officially on the run
and what alexander now cares about is
continuing this adventure continuing it
east into what we now consider to be
afghanistan turkmenistan uzbekistan and
and modern-day pakistan he also wants to
get darius
some would argue he wants to kill him
himself some would argue that he wants
to somehow have darius declare alexander
as the the rightful shan shah king of
asia and so you can see the path of
alexander and his forces after they
destroy persepolis they then go up they
turn northwards and they go through all
of these cities up here then in 329
they're on the they're following the
trail of darius
darius eventually gets captured and
killed by one of his traps someone by
the name of bessus and bessus who is one
of the traps of bactria
kills darius
and declares himself artaxerces v he
wants to be the shan shah well
eventually alexander catches up with
bessus in 329. he's really angry that
bessis has killed darius he's also
likely angry that vessus is claiming
that he's the shansha and so he kills
bessis in fairly brutal form and there's
different accounts of how the the
killing happened but all of them are
various degrees of brutal but from there
alexander's troops continued on eastward
continued on eastward into what we now
consider to be
afghanistan and pakistan and there he
has the famous battle
with the king of porus
where he encounters these 200 war
elephants but once again he's this great
military tactician and he's able to
defeat the king and along this whole way
it's worth mentioning he sets up all of
these towns he sets up 20 alexandrias
and near here even sets up a town named
after his horse bucephalus the town of
bucephala and alexander is eager to keep
conquering once he defeats the king of
porus he says hey i want to go conquer
the rest of india
but his troops are far from home and
they're tired and they're spread thin
and they're getting sick they're not so
interested in that so eventually
alexander says all right i'm i'm with
you all
let's go back and the troops are really
really happy they make their way back
you can see the path back after their
and you could see it as they follow the
indus river in pakistan and eventually
we get to 3
23 323
bce and alexander is back in babylon
and it's over there in babylon that
alexander dies at the ripe old age of
32. it's mind-blowing to think about how
much happened in the 12 years that he
was emperor of the macedonians or even
the shah and shah of persia
he was able to defeat an empire over 200
years old and what's significant about
this is that as he conquered he
encouraged his troops to assimilate in
fact he was criticized for maybe
assimilating a little bit too much but
he dies in babylon and it's not clear
exactly why he dies he was a major
drinker some people say alcohol
poisoning some people say it was direct
poisoning but needless to say
this was one of the the most significant
decades in human history this this this
conquest of alexander the great